It's a question that's puzzled filmmakers
for generations: how do you show a cinematic
divine being?
From Star Trek V...
"Excuse me, I'd just like to ask a question...what
does God need with a starship?"
...to Clash of the Titans...
"Release the Kraken!"
...movies have wrestled with how to show God
and gods on the big screen.
And the hottest ticket in Hollywood the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is no exception to this
struggle.
Marvel Studios has already made multiple feature
films starring members belonging to the pantheon
of Norse gods.
Charlie Wen, former head of visual development
at Marvel Studios, led his team to design
the cinematic versions of Thor and his Asgardian
pals.
We sat down with Wen for an exclusive interview
and he explained that two very important members
of Thor's immediate family almost looked very,
very different.
Odin and Loki Thor's dad and adopted brother,
respectively were first drawn in Marvel Comics
by the legendary Jack Kirby, who probably
didn't draw many or any actual mythological
details to bring them to the page.
Both debuted shortly after Thor's own first
comic book appearance in Journey into Mystery
#83 in 1962.
But even though they both showed up right
around the same time in the funnybooks, their
looks couldn't have been more different in
terms of design and even simple consistency.
Loki's costume from Journey into Mystery #85
may not be a pretty sight, but it is an excellent
example of how to design a bad guy.
Where Thor wears blue, red, and has graceful
looking wings on his helmet, Loki is a perfect
contrast to those details.
His outfit consists of blue and red's color-wheel
contrasts green and yellow and instead of
a headpiece with wings that angle backward,
his own outfit features aggressive horns that
jut outward.
While Loki's look has evolved over the years,
these have been constant features that appear
in nearly every incarnation.
Odin, on the other hand, couldn't be less
consistent or defined.
Odin's first appearance, sporting a style
best described as "comic book viking stuff,"
only reveals his head, appearing in the clouds
over Thor, Mufasa style.
"Look inside yourself, Simba.
You are more than what you have become.
You must take your place in the circle of
life!"
His next batch of appearances are no clearer,
with various designs that include assortments
of helmets, capes, more helmets, furs, and
what sure seems to be a cummerbund with a
lightning bolt hastily drawn on it.
"It's a lightning bolt!
With extra powers!"
Considering how important and powerful Odin
is supposed to be, he might want to try getting
dressed in front of a mirror for once.
And maybe fire whatever crappier Norse gods
have the job of dressing him.
The Allfather's look continued to evolve each
time he appeared, making it seem like artists
relished the opportunity to use him for experiments
with new space-viking designs.
Even when writer-artist Walt Simonson took
control of steering the Asgardian royal family's
adventures with Thor #337, Odin never stayed
in one outfit for long.
Simonson's run is famous for introducing Beta
Ray Bill, Frog Thor, and that incredible scene
when Skurge machine-guns a bunch of demons,
but his Odin remains as impossible to pin
down as anyone else's.
When Charlie Wen became the head of visual
development at Marvel Studios, one of his
first tasks was adapting the mythical land
of Asgard and its powerful inhabitants for
the first Thor movie, which arrived in 2011.
And that meant trying to define the looks
for Thor's immediate family members.
But before he could settle on a specific direction,
Wen first had to find directions he wanted
to avoid.
That's why he came up with this version of
Thor's villainous brother, which Wen calls
"Loony Loki."
While Loony Loki retains the classic green
and gold colors from the comics, nearly every
other element seems transformed.
Wen explained:
"Loki's horns are — it's really represented
in this floating shape that's behind him that
also changes.
And it'll float back up into shapes that you'll
recognize as being his horns."
"it was more like, how do we still capture
that character but in sort of unique ways?"
This version of the character was never really
meant to show up on film in fact, this design
came about before there was a finished script,
and before director Kenneth Branagh came onto
the project to direct.
Rather, Wen was experimenting, seeing how
far out of shape Loki could be bent before
he became unrecognizable.
"Here I was trying to push it as far as I
could.
So, it was more like I understood the icon
but let me try to rip it as far apart from
that while still trying to maintain who that
is.
And, it probably broke at some point but it's
like, that's actually what you're trying to
do is understand how far do you go until it
actually breaks?
And this was one of those explorations of
I need to push this."
"When I show that to people that are just
big Loki fans there's just terror, everyone's
like, 'I'm so glad that it wasn't like that.'
But, I mean we needed to go there."
Loki wasn't the only character to get stretched
past the breaking point.
Because of Odin's ever-changing fashion, there's
not much Wen could've done in his early designs
that would've been too out of bounds.
It's fascinating to imagine the Asgard Wen
was building early on, since it seems like
it would've gone more into Thor's sci-fi elements
than the Shakespearean super-fantasy we got
instead.
And on that note, this concept art of Odin,
his outfit, and his choice of furniture speak
volumes about the movie that could have been.
"The MCU is filled with magic but that magic
is really science that we don't understand,
right?
And so, that was the premise that was set
up both on Iron Man and onto Thor, right?
So, Thor's is this magical world, this realm
that we didn't understand but we wanted it
to still be based in science."
Let's look at Odin's chair, which consists
of floating platforms that seem to have eventually
appeared in the first Guardians of the Galaxy
movie for Thanos' throne.
Wen explained this design was part of an earlier
idea for how magic and science would come
together in Asgard.
The Rainbow Bridge, for instance, would form
as floating platforms that would appear as
a person crossed it.
When Asgard's design shifted to the more fantasy-based
style that we saw in the Thor movies, Odin's
floaty throne went away.
Which, according to Wen, was probably helpful
for at least one actor.
"Thank goodness for Anthony Hopkins that he
didn't have to sit on anything like that."
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.